aujourd'hui dans l'actu on parle souvent
du bac on en oublierait le brevet des
collèges le nombre de reçus en 2012 est
supérieur aux années précédentes les
Yveline est le département le moins LTI
de l'académie de Versailles
l'association culturelle de trappe
n'existe plus depuis 25 ans algérien
notamment la Merise c'est dorénavant une
régie municipale autonome qui prendra en
charge la programmation culturelle de la
commune le but selon les élus faire
revenir les trapistes dans la salle de
spectacle être à son travail un peu
comme à la maison un siège social à
l'américaine avec table de billard
cuisine équipée et salle de sport c'est
le concept du nouveau siège social
d'antemeta la société qui propose des
solutions de gestion de données a quitté
Voisins le bretonneux pour Guill en cour
créé en 1995 elle a réalisé 37,4
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et puis versaill en 3D comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu des films en 3D sont
désormais installés dans les
appartements du du château de Versailles
pour permettre aux visiteurs de
comprendre comment ce lieu a évolué et
il est devenu une résidence royale riche
d'enseignement on parle souvent du bac
on en oublierait le DBN entendait le
diplôme national du brevet le fameux
brevet des collèges dans l'académie de
Versailles qui regroupe quatre
départements les yvelin les hautes scèes
les sonnes et le valdoise le taux de
réussite est de 87,5 % il est en
augmentation de 1,4 points par rapport à
l'année dernière à noter que parmi ces
quatre départements ce sont les Yvelines
qui affichent le plus fort taux de
réussite avec près de 90 % de reçus
encore en matière de chiffre 55,6 % des
candidats au brevet ont obtenu une
mention et là encore le département des
Yvelines affiche un nombre plus
important de mentions très bien avec
1813 collégiens en tout cette année
66891 candidats se sont présentés au
brevet
lact n'existe plus l'association
culturelle de trappe qui gérait la salle
de spectacle la Merise et le cinéma
lerenier àel a donc disparu après 25 ans
de service la directrice et le
secrétaire général ont quitté la
structure c'est donc une régie
municipale autonome qui va remplacer
l'association nous avions nous envie élu
de
repartir plutôt
sur quel quelque chose qui soit très lié
à la population avec des commissions
avec du travail vraiment en profondeur
avec les comités de quartier la ville
les habitants de la ville il y avait des
choses très bien faites sans doute avec
les écoles ou avec certaines écoles mais
il y avait peu de choses faites
réellement avec la population on sait
bien que trape compte énormément
d'associations les associations
n'avaient plus guerre accès à la
merurise et de ce fait la population de
trappe ne venait ne vient plus à la
meurise actuellement une baisse de
fréquentation qui a commencé depuis 3
ans en moyenne la salle accueille 100
personnes par spectacle sur une capacité
minimum de 700 places brigitte glachan
est l'ancienne présidente de
l'association culturelle de trappe elle
est restée pendant 15 ans au conseil
d'administration cette disparition de la
CT ne l'étonne pas mais la déçoit on
l'avait déjà évoqué avec le maire c'est
pas parce qu'on municipalise non plus
que ça va être tout simple maintenant et
qu'on va pouvoir réinvestir la merurise
comme ils le disent et la rendre aux
habitants on a tout fait pour euh en
arrivé là c'est pas l'histoire de la
municipalisation c'est l'histoire de la
non fréquentation qui est un vrai
problème et puis maintenant je suis très
inquiète sur ce qui va se passer sur
comme politique culturelle sur la ville
de trappe est-ce qu'on va continuer à
faire une vraie présence culturelle avec
des spectacles et cetera pour rendre la
meurise aux habitants la mairie mise
donc sur un nouveau directeur Claude
drobinski qui a été directeur
administratif du théâtre de
Saint-Quentin et ancien directeur des
affaires culturelles à la mairie de
trappe j'ai travaillé avec les
associations et donc je pense que toute
cette cette connaissance de
de du public des différentes des
associations bon sera un élément qui
facilitera la mise en place d'un d'un
projet on
va créer une des
commissions qui vont travailler sur
l'envie d'ouvrir de faire des temps
forts je sais pas j'ai en tête des temps
fort caraïbé un projet d'aménagement de
la meurise est à l'étude pour notamment
créer des salles afin d'accueillir des
artistes en résidence et un café musique
si les subventions sont obtenues les
travaux pourraient démarrer à l'été 2013
quant au grenier à cel pas de changement
dans l'organisation le cinéma va même
faire pot neuf cet été et sera équipé du
tout numérique la mairie promet de son
côté que les subventions allouées à la
salle de spectacle ne seront pas revu à
la baisse la reprise de saison de la
meurise est prévue début
octobre
salle de sport et sa douche billard baby
food cuisine équipée nous ne sommes pas
dans les locaux d'une entreprise de la
silicone vallée mais bien au nouveau
siège d'une société yvelinoise aguill
encour en temeta non je me suis pas
inspiré de modèle américain je pense que
simplement je m'inspire du fait que
aujourd'hui mes collaborateurs ont
besoin de par le stress qu'ils ont
potentiellement d'avoir des moments de
repos ils l'apprécient ou des moments de
détente je leur donne les moyens d'avoir
ces moments chez nous en faisant ça
est-ce du
paternalisme parce que on va me dire ou
mais du coup vous les gardez au sein de
l'entreprise ils sortent pas peuvent
sortir si je leur donne les moyens de se
détendre chez chez nous dans les
meilleures conditions tout va bien
résultat des employés qui seraient plus
motivé plus efficac et surtout fidèle à
l'entreprise spécialisé dans le stockage
et le traitement de données
informatiques la valeur c'est mes
collaborateurs c'est important de
conserver de valoriser ses
collaborateurs c'est marche que
aujourd'hui on doit avoir et cette
stratégie semble efficace moins de 10
ans après avoir fondé anteméa dans son
garage avec C collaborateur Stéphane
blanc emploie aujourd'hui plus de 100
personnes la majorité ici dans ses
locaux de 3500 m Carr mais aussi dans
des antennes à Nant et à Strasbourg elle
compte plus de 800 clients à travers le
monde son chiffre d'affaires autour de
35 millions
d'euros éveil desessens et découverte de
la plaine de Versailles chaque année les
labyrins é mère de la ferme de Gal à
saint-cir l'école séduisent les
visiteurs cet été trois parcours sont
proposés au milieu des fleurs et des
maïs c'est pour ça qu'on fait plusieurs
labyrinthes on les a adapté suivant les
âges donc il y en a avec des boîtes
sensorielles donc plus accès sur
l'essence évidemment et puis assez
facile de cheminement et puis d'autres
un peu plus complexes avec des belles
photos historiques sur le parc du
château de Versailles on SIME au
printemps hein les les bonnes graines
les fleurs le maïs et cetera et après il
poussent et après après on choisit
nous-mêm les cheminements à l'intérieur
du labyrinthe avec un jeu de piste avec
des étapes pour que les enfants se
perdent se retrouvent et puis joue en
même temps évidemment les labyrinthes
s'étendent sur près de 4 hectares et
seront ouverts tous les jours sauf le
lundi jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août et
durant les weekends de septembre à noter
également que d'ici à 2 ans une
structure pérenne sera proposée près de
8000 visiteurs sont attendus ici durant
l'éténi le château de versaill ne ce de
sur prendre le public en se réinventant
loin d'être figé dans le temps le
domaine du Roi Soleil s'ouvre au
nouvelles technologies et signe un
partenariat avec Google c'est un
partenariat exemplaire puisque c'est
l'alliance de la connaissance
scientifique historique de nos
conservateur et puis de la d'un
savoir-faire technologique sans paril
celui de Google et les deux ensemble
sont complémentaires en fait une équipe
internationale environ une cinquantaine
de personnes à travaillé pendant plus
d'un an pour développer l'ensemble bah
des comment dire des maquettes et des
différentes expériences digitales qu'on
peut retrouver dans les salles du
château de Versailles et également sur
le site internet n'importe où dans le
monde l'internaute accède au domaine de
Versailles depuis son ordinateur en se
connectant au site
versailles3d.com le château et son parc
modélisés selon cinq dates clés
permettent de retracer l'évolution
architecturale de Versailles point de
départ 1624 avec le pavillon de chasse
de Louis XI suivra le règne de Louis XIV
qui fait agrandir le château et s'y
installe Louis XV commande l'opéra
royale et Louis XV connaît la Révolution
française qui vide le château de ses
meubles sous le Premier Empire en 1804
Napoléon réaménage le Grand Trianon
Louis XI rétablit la symétrie du château
puis Louis-Philippe le transforme en
musée historique à la fin du 19e siècle
la République française prend possession
de Versailles cette visite virtuelle
fait écho à l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
galerie consacrée à l'histoire du
château 11 salles pour résumer 5 siècles
de vie et de création on cherchait à
résoudre cette équation de trouver un
lieu déjà dans le château pour montrer
des repères sur ce château qui soit
cohérent évidemment avec l'ensemble de
la visite et cohérent aussi avec les
parcours de visite la galerie de
l'histoire du château située près de la
chapelle royale en début de circuit
offre une bonne introduction aux
visiteurs avant la découverte de la
galerie des glaces et des appartements
royauuxx